Marseille has the highest unemployment
rate in France over one-third of young
people here are without work Enzo is fed
up he wants change and is convinced the
far right for Nacional can bring it
about he's a great admirer of malya
malya shall depend granddaughter of
jean-marie Le Pen the party's original
founder just 26 she's the rising star of
the French far-right and already a
member of the French National Assembly
she recently stood for election in the
Provos out cote d'azur constituency
which includes marseille and nice smart
lyon is young she represents a new era
she's the ideal face of the whole nación
ah she performs well in debates and
upholds the party line her achievements
are impressive we're all so young and
seeing a young woman reach such Heights
at such a young age is inspiring the
pawl nacional wants to see france leave
the EU and a return to the french franc
the party is convinced that the only way
france can overcome the debt crisis is
to go it alone when we have political
parties ignoring french homeless people
and showing immigrants preferential
treatment where is the fraternity in
that we are proud of our identity we're
taking the French flag that other
parties have cast into the gutter and
are holding it high again
her insistence on France as Laughlin's
nación goes down well with the younger
generation even if it's a term most of
them only know from history books we're
taught in school that we're a great
people there was the French Revolution
in 1789
we have Napoleon we have the Kings but
now France has relinquished its
sovereignty to Europe but we don't care
about Europe at all
many young people are proud of French
history over a third of them voted for
the floor Nacional in the first round of
regional elections in the south the
figure was even higher in recent years
the established parties have veered from
one corruption scandal to the next
observers say they failed to address the
crisis the setting domestic politics
France is the poor man of Europe not
because the French are the worst off but
because problems aren't being solved
there are five million people unemployed
and no solution whatsoever in sight and
now we have an identity problem all
parties including the floor Nacional
like to cite the illustrious history of
the French Republic the trouble is that
France doesn't know how to find its
place in today's globalized world enzo
and his friends are working
round-the-clock campaigning format leon
mother shall depend he agrees with her
avowal that immigrants are responsible
for the problems in france marseille is
traditionally catholic but the city is
now home to some 130,000 muslims no
party has managed to find ways that
could boost their integration the
reality is that rival gangs of drug
dealers dominate the city's Muslim
neighborhoods
what's up former president Sarkozy
didn't follow his own words he promised
to clean up the immigrant neighborhoods
but he didn't do anything in cities all
over France there are neighborhoods that
even police dare not enter for Enzo the
Frog Nacional is the only party that can
help it has no remedy for the high
unemployment rate but that doesn't seem
to bother him he thinks the problem will
be solved once the parties in government
he has blind faith in the four nastyona
but not all of its leaders are as
charming as Matthew O'Malley shall
depend Stephan Xavier a member of the
French Senate and a local mayor in
Marseille borders Enzo to stop talking
to us in no uncertain terms you know
what you can do with that camera you
like the press do you you've been with
us eight days and you are already
chatting away you need to learn some
discipline oh you are out of here I'll
give you the mic back
so speaking to the press is a no-go
the floor nacionales leaders are
determined to control the party's lower
echelon zat any price on the eve of the
second round of regional elections we
can't find Enzo at the Party
headquarters he obviously hasn't been
allowed in Malley O'Malley shall depend
gives a victory speech even though she
didn't win the seat despite her defeat
she won't be softening her stance on
immigrants the press the other party's
these cynical profiteers who think they
can scare us off our path to them I say
you're wrong we'll double our efforts
and our fighting spirit is undampening
the South of France has the wind in its
sails before Nacional now has three
times more support than it did six years
ago mainly thanks to a younger
generation that fears for the future and
is easy prey for populist sand rabble
rousers